as buckingham palace announces the queen
intends to work through heb out of covid
this week the prime minister wants us
all to do the same set to announce plans
to end self-isolation in england boris
johnson wants the country to learn to
live with the virus to avoid a return to
scenes like this deserted streets at the
height of lockdown
but along with ending self-isolation
free covert tests are expected to end
for most of us too and someone it will
make spotting new cases which could harm
vulnerable people more difficult
well i'm particularly concerned about
the end of free testing i mean it's a
bit like being 2-1 up with 10 minutes
left of play and subbing your best
defender we are not out of the woods yet
on kovid and it's important that when
the government publishes its plan for
living with clover tomorrow that it is a
robust plan that enables everyone to
live well with kovid and others in the
medical profession worry the evidence
isn't there to support lifting
restrictions a month early and that this
is more about a political boost for the
prime minister we know that in a country
like denmark that have actually
eradicated or they've ended rules around
isolation
and other measures that the cases have
rocketed so we think this is a premature
decision it's not based on data
and it's unnecessary at this moment when
we should be protecting people
and the government hasn't put in place
any of those explanations but has made
an announcement one month early which we
believe therefore becomes a political
announcement not one that's based upon
the interests of the public's health the
plan the prime minister will announce
tomorrow is a risk but the government
believes it's a calculated one there are
still questions about testing about
tracking new variants and protecting the
most vulnerable but boris johnson wants
us all to take a leaf out of the queen's
book to get vaccinated to take sensible
precautions but most importantly to keep
on going and he hopes this calculated
risk will be enough to prove to the
country and his restive back benches
that he's still the man for the job
for some learning to live with kovid
won't be easy the fear that came with
the simplest of tasks in those early
days still feels very real but the prime
minister knows businesses and lots of
families around the country are
desperate to move on and he believes now
is the time to begin kate mccann sky
news